the gas prices now in california are so  high they are higher than  post-apocalyptic crappy film i am legend  i'm a survivor living in new york city  i am broadcasting on all am frequencies  that was supposed to be shocking  there's some consultants on there like  hey maybe we should boost it to 695. now  the keys it's got to be believable it's  got to be horrifying enough that it'll  scare people but you just you can't you  can't show the monster right away think  about that for a second when we say that  it's beyond parody that's a  post-apocalyptic film yeah  yeah a group of people sat there and  were like look it you just can't get  higher than that nobody's gonna believe  it and people at the so that's like the  high end in what is it l.a county san  francisco kind of bay area yeah they're  looking at it  that's tuesday right